he has thrown in 114 and two-thirds
innings only allowed 89 hits in that
time
which is a very good 208 batting average
against a lot of good numbers across the
board for mccullers throughout his
career very
very good at minutemate park he's
starting to put it together on the road
very well as well oh two
swing gonna miss make it seven career
punch-outs against mccullers for
henniger he goes down on the slider and
that's mccullar's first strikeout two
away swinging and a mess mccullers gets
him on the curve ball and it's a one two
three first for lance a couple of
strikeouts to boot he will be making his
23rd start at 3.82 era that record
almost at 500 at least the astros are
going to try and make it that way
against houston he is 1-1 with a
era one on and one out for carlos correa
astros shortstop
in the air right center field pretty
well hit sending kellnick all the way
back and it's off the wall
that'll send brantley to third correa
with a double braley's gonna be waved
around and he'll score
it's a triple for carlos correa the
astros on the board one to nothing
here's alvarez with correa at third and
one out first pitch
ground ball pulled right side this will
get a run in fielded by france he takes
the first himself alvarez is out correa
scores two nothing astros ground ball
right side off to his left is toro he's
got it the throne of first and it's in
time to get guriel and that's going to
retire the side however the astros get
two
on just one base hit we go to the top
half of the second one out of nobody on
for abraham toro
that's a ground ball right side into the
shift to his right altuve and short
right and he throws out toro
two away he's a good grinder of a player
isn't he torah certainly is
ground ball past mccullers it'll be a
tough play for diaz on the move he gets
fairly three ground ball outs for lance
mccullers jr and he's off to a good
start with the astros leading two to
nothing
now it's jake myers with mccormick at
first and one out 313 average in 12
games 371 on base percentage two homers
five runs batted in the one-two
and that's hit in the air pretty deep to
center field going back as kelnick at
the wall he leaves and that ball is gone
a two-run home run for jake myers and
the astros have opened up a four to
nothing lead
fastball strike three call
altuve caught looking good fastball at
the knees from you say kikuchi that is
strikeout number one for you say here's
the stretch and the next offer on the
way swinging a heartache ground ball
right to france at first backhands it
goes to the bag steps on the pillow for
the out on brantley and that will retire
the side but the astros add two more in
the home run by jake myers lance
mccallers six up six down so far
including a couple of strikeouts here's
the one two and it's a breaking ball
strike three slider low and away to
torrance he goes down on strikes there's
one out
third strikeout for lance
good call 2-2 breaking ball and he picks
up a strikeout back-to-back case four in
the game for lance
breaking ball grounded first baseline
fair or foul it's going to be fair right
by the first baseband guriel scoops it
up steps on
first base simultaneously and that'll do
it correa did not have any triples this
year before that triple off the wall on
right center field
there's a sharply hit ground ball
through the hole between short and third
correa two for two and now nine of his
last 16 over the last five games here's
big jordan alvarez he had a an rbi in
the first inning on a ground out with
the runner on third base and the first
pitch is driven to center
back on it kellnick looking up
see you later two-run homer for jordan
alvarez and the astros lead six nothing
they've scored two runs in each inning
julie guriel drives one deep to left
field back to back jacked by the cubanos
yardon and yuli make it seven to nothing
struck out his last time up the 30 year
old
oh he dots him up on the outside corner
haniger just turns around
throws them on the fastball goes down
for the second out of the inning two
down here in the top half of the fourth
inning and 11 in a row retired by the
cullers here at the start of the ball
game here's a swing and a high fly ball
deep to right field zigger going out to
right field and goodbye baseball into
the second level kyle seeger with the
first hit of the night off of lance
mccullers for seeger his 28th home run
of the season and that thing was a bomb
the 1-1
it's a hook and it's popped up left
field easy play for brantley four steps
to his right pats his glove makes the
catch and that's out number three they
get a run though mariners get a homer by
kyle sager yordon will bat with two on
here and nobody out
yordon to left field going back on his
freely that ball is
gone but the fan may have reached over
we're gonna get interference called on
the fan so that'll be a double it'll
still score a run brantley will come
home from second freely through the
sunglasses back to
toss and
don't get hurt
sunglasses pal take it easy yuli
guriel's got a chance to drive in a
couple of the infield will come in
julie into center field with the infield
in that's a beautiful thing
in to score correa alvarez will be held
at third rbi single by guriel
back-to-back base hits for julie and the
astros lead 9-1
mccormick hits a high-fly ball in the
right field this should be deep enough
to score alvarez camping under it as
haniger alvarez will tag he'll trot home
sacrifice flying an rbi for chaz
mccormick astros with double figures in
this game they now lead at 10 to 1.
that's the colors man he's been tough
tonight got that slider fastball
combination working and also working in
the change up the last two innings
oh he got him throws him on a fastball
at 95 96 miles an hour mccullers strikes
out torrance for his sixth strike out of
the night
go to the whip there is kellnick
frustrated with that swing as he has
gone down twice to lance mccullers jr
lance with back-to-back strikeouts has
seven k's on the game now the noddle
leads off a single and a walk tonight
maldonado hits the ball high and deep to
left field fraley back looking up this
ball's gone
martin maldonado
makes it 11 for the astros with his home
run number nine on the air
astros have scored in every inning
ground ball right side in field back
that's an easy rbi for brantley altuve
trots home
and the astros now with an even dozen it
is 12-1
toro was hit by a pitch last time 3-2
swung online drive center field base hit
france will come in and score mariners
have their second run abraham toro with
an rbi single
ground ball towards correa two big hops
carlos will make the throw in time and
that'll do it for the mariners in the
sixth inning lance mccullers goes six
innings tonight picks up eight
strikeouts and he'll leave with the
astros leading 12-2
taking over here in the seventh inning
got him swinging strike three kel nick
reese for the slider and there's one
away here in the seventh now the o2
and he got him strike three rayleigh
dazzling with two quick strikeouts here
in the seventh
slider strike three got him looking
bowers goes down and brooks raley
strikes out three here in the seventh
we'll go to the stretch
at minuteman
double right center field in the sixth
the single to center in the fourth oh he
got a pitch at tomahawk that baby out of
here ty france i'm talking about
railroad ties
rbi number 56 tori tori hitting pace
he's on right now yeah he's been hot new
pitcher for the astros coming in here in
the ninth inning is jimmy garcia here's
the 2-2
strike three call at the knees on the
outside corner raleigh not happy but
that is the ball game the houston astros
hit four home runs and blitz the
mariners early
and win this one 12-3